oui c'est insupportable à Paris tu es
devenu n'importe quoi il y a des il y a
des rares partout il y a des guerres
partout il y a il y a des travaux
partout cessez de venir en enfer cette
ville non il a plus à Paris qu'ailleurs
mais la plus apparition tu le sais Emile
tu le sais oui Paris c'est un truc oui
mais des travaux pourquoi si c'est des
travaux pour faire des pistes cyclables
pour réduire la voiture on en peut plus
dépistage tu peux même plus comment tu
fais quand tu es une personne
âgée
comment tu fais pas faire de ma
grand-mère elle peut pas faire du vélo
elle fait du judo oui mais pas du vélo
elle conduit mais elle peut avoir un
taxi alors il y a peu de taxi à Paris tu
as vu à cause de vous mais à cause de
vous il y a plus de taxi à Paris tu
paries comment on attaqué les paris ne
veulent plus travailler l'après-midi
juste Emile je t'explique il y a plus un
taxi à Paris parce que les taxis ne
volent plus travailler ni l'après-midi
ni le matin parce que il y a trop de
vous avez tellement flingué par I et qui
ne veulent plus ils ne travaillent que
le soir maintenant tu peux appeler
n'importe quel taxi voilà exactement
donc ça veut dire que non mais comment
ça se fait pas Paris c'est un
supportable pour vous stoppez vous soyez
venu pour vous stoppez parce que c'est
un moment
Cyril juste peut-être un mot oui on
s'est fait lire sur un programme qui
était de baisser la pollution à Paris
mais elle a rien bosser du tout arrêter
bien sûr ça arrive à changer le monde on
a une cacahuète alors non la pollution à
Paris je vous parle de la pollution qui
va poumons de vous arrêter etc aussi on
a été élu pour la faire baisser a été
commandé par la Mairie de Paris bien sûr
comment vous faites pour baisser la
pollution bah c'est les voitures
c'est les poussières fines c'est les gaz
d'échappement vous avez fait on a une
politique
le nombre de gens que vous avez mis au
chômage vous rendez compte le nombre de
magasins qui sont obligés de fermer à
cause de vous parce que les travaux
novembre le nombre de chauffeurs de taxi
de chauffeur uber qui sont dans la merde
c'est à cause de vos conneries là il y a
des abeilles et des guêpes qu'il faut
protéger mais toi
arrête un peu à maman un moment
l'écologie il faut il faut faire il faut
faire le bon la bonne balance entre
écologie et économie là vous êtes en
train de flinguer l'économie il y a des
millions de gens des millions de
milliers tu as rien qui se retrouvent au
chômage à cause de vous parce qu'on va
sauver trois guêtres
qui se dépeuple Paris exactement c'est
la seule capitale qui se développe les
gens n'aiment plus à Paris même les
étrangers ils veulent plus venir à Paris
mais moi je te dis les choses de Paris
vous vous suivez la panse et bah moi non
voilà
alors non mais on peut tout mettre dans
un pot c'est facile on se fait plaisir
sur les commerces par exemple je vous
donne un exemple précis on a fait des
des rues on a piétonnisé on l'a fait
avec les commerçants on l'a fait avec
les habitants qu'est-ce qu'on remarque
le chiffre d'affaires augmente
[Applaudissements]
je te jure
dans la merde à cause de vous on va pas
tous en Ferrari faire son shopping
rodrivoli qui moi je te parle j'en sais
rien à l'abeille
je parle des habitants par exemple du
18e ou pas on a fait une identité
[Musique]
moi aussi alors ça c'est le premier
point Tunis malheureusement
climatique et bah c'est justement ce que
fait le Qatar avec ces 7 dans le désert
ça participe et pourquoi pas c'est venu
l'enfer pourquoi la question elle est là
vous avez vous avez pas remarqué vous
avez pas remarqué que tous les parisiens
deviennent fous pourquoi il y a autant
de rats à Paris pourquoi il y a des
travaux partout à Paris pourquoi il y a
des guêpes toute la journée dans une
terrasse pourquoi c'est sale Paris frère
j'ai jamais vu une ville aussi sale
c'est dégueulasse ça me dégoûte tout le
monde est dégoûté de Paris c'est la vie
la plus belle du monde vous avez rendu
la dépouille
merci à toi
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu te rends compte que tu
peux pas avoir un chauffeur de taxi en
après-midi tu peux pas faire
[Musique]
c'est toi qui a dit les taxi au début ok
alors les gens d'abord ils prennent le
métro c'est bon
tu as vu l'état du métro les gens qui
vont qui vont travailler que tu crois
qu'ils prennent tout sur le taxi
mais donc tu es en train de me dire
qu'une personne âgée ne peut plus vivre
à Paris mais bien sûr si avec les écoles
une personne
de la rue de Rivoli on peut tous riches
il faut aller en 18e des gens qui
habitent bien sûr
tu as vu je suis content pour les
centaines de milliers de signes mais on
est content mais pour s'en servir
par exemple les familles nombreuses
elles peuvent pas être hello par exemple
il y a des gens qui prennent le métro
les vélos les trottinettes hein les
trottinettes les vélos tu as vu tous les
morts qu'il y a en vélo en trottinette
font n'importe quoi mais donne-moi des
chiffres arrête un peu c'est un drame et
trottinette sinon tous les jours tu sais
ce que je suis en train de faire des
commissariat tu sais ce que sont en
train de faire les commissariats je vais
te dire un truc tu vois et là tu vas
peut-être la prendre parce que c'est
bien sympa vos petits conseils là entre
vous là à dire des conneries là je sais
pas quoi au Conseil de Paris
de bras casser là mais moi je vais te le
dire
tu sais ce qu'il faut comme il sait rien
maintenant quand il y a un accident de
trottinette ils font exprès de venir à
plusieurs pour le signaler parce qu'ils
veulent arrêter les trottinettes et à
Paris je te le dis et les vélos parce
qu'ils ont peur d'être appelé toute la
journée pour des accidents donc voilà
arrête un peu tu le sais arrête
mais on veut les arrêter les
trottinettes arrêtez-les ben c'est ce
qu'on va faire parce que il y a des lois
vous savez il y a une il y a une libre
entreprise ils sont venus les
trottinettes en trifleting nous on en
replie parce que justement on constate
que ça pose des problèmes principalement
d'ailleurs toi tu es génial
donc on a David Belliard vous avez pas
été très gentil avec lui il a l'air très
sympa David Belliard c'est celui qui
veut arrêter les trottinettes et la
Cabaye alors il est bien de Paris la
prochaine élections faut voter pour les
écolosse
beaucoup il y a chaque fois
pourquoi il y a autant de guêpes à Paris
pourquoi c'est quoi l'histoire
climatique
d'un menteur tu as raison c'est pas pour
ça
c'est à cause de vous c'est sûr parce
qu'on a mis du sucre dans le café
avec les guêpes vous avez pas enlever
les trucs là sur les toiles là les trucs
là n'importe quoi
il y a des ruches exactement
[Applaudissements]
tu m'as pris pour un avocat Dubourg je
crois que je sais mais voilà les
abeilles
à chaque fois je vais prendre un café
j'ai des abeilles autour de moi
c'est horrible c'est horrible vous avez
[ __ ] par une blague Cyril
il y a plus de vie on les abeilles on ne
mange pas très bien elle est mariée à
Émile
les mecs je veux bien des abeilles je
veux bien des rats mais à maman il y en
a trop les aides on peut plus vivre à
Paris je te jure tu as plus de fleurs
on a plus d'armes on a plus de pollution
et ben je suis content excusez-moi la
pollution je suis content on fait des
parcs je suis content aussi on construit
des logements sociaux pour loger les
gens
aussi il y a des rares en fait c'est toi
aussi les races
[Applaudissements]
je peux te dire qu'ils ont peu plus ils
veulent tout s'arrêter ils m'ont dit on
n'en peux plus avec cette mairie on n'en
peut plus on va arrêter les chauffeurs
de taxi veulent arrêter les magasins
veulent arrêter les éboueurs veulent
arrêter mais qui va nous rester vous
avez réussi incroyable c'est qu'en fait
personne n'est content
ni les vélos ni les cyclistes
tu vas peut-être pécho
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé en tant que ça m'arrive
quand même excusez-moi de parler avec
des gens c'est un peu mon job toute la
journée et pardon Cyril j'entends pas
tout ce que tu dis c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai alors c'est facile de faire
plaisir on regarde on voit on regarde
Twitter on voit les il y a une vidéo les
accidents de vélo 35 % en 2020 dans la
capitale mais c'est pas vrai
les accidents de vélo en hausse de plus
de 35 % en 2020 la capitale voilà j'ai
rien d'autre pardon les 35% de hausse
des accidents de vélo dans la capitale
ça sert à rien
ils ont mis plein de ruches sur les
toits ils sont protégés donc tu as vu tu
as mis plein de ruches sur les toits les
écolos je le sais
du béton tu peux plus aller en terrasse
sans avoir des guêpes qui viennent des
abeilles qui viennent te [ __ ] ta
gueule
[Rires]
trop de travaux trop de décès trop de
travaux
de travaux trop de déchets et des rats
prolifèrent voilà ce que me dire Hotman
en tout cas je suis content
je pense que tu te sentiras mieux ce
soir je te jure tu m'as fait plaisir de
te prendre dans mes bras
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas si je vous ai convaincu mais
en tout cas j'ai essayé ah tu m'as fait
du bien Emile tu m'as fait du bien tu
vas pas bien à la maison ce soir
t'inquiète pas j'habite pas à Paris il y
aura pas de rail y aura pas d'abeille
moi je mange du tofu et je vais en vélo
donc toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on rigole bien
je te jure Emile tu es excellent je te
jure
et pour les abeilles aussi arrête avec
ça non je te jure eh ma mère elle est en
train de vous défoncer par SMS
de bureau faire un parc juste Emile
c'est ça le projet toi bien sûr
dans le 18e arrondissement il y a un
petit peu de race c'est vrai il faut
qu'on fasse des choses contre ça je
regarde depuis 2018 tiens la lecture
rose maladie mortelle une fois sur trois
atteint des niveaux records à Paris
alors qu'elle était quasi éradiquée il y
a 30 ans il vaut mieux présumer les
abeilles ou la santé des parisiens ou
les rats laisse revenir et les rats j'ai
envie de les fracasser ça c'est ma mère
c'est une étude de très précise on peut
aussi dire la vérité bon moi je pense
qu'on fait des bonnes actions alors
visiblement tu les ressens pas comme ça
bon sur les rails il y a un sujet ça
c'est une réalité un sujet alors après
en fait pas des patrouilles de rats la
nuit pour réguler moi j'y vais moi sur
ma vie il y a des politiques publiques à
mettre en place et espace principalement
par la réduction des déchets pourquoi
parce qu'en fait plus il y a de déchets
plus il y a à manger plus les rapports
diffèrent vous diminuez les déchets vous
diminuez les rats
bien sûr il y a une histoire de
politique de ramassage aussi donc c'est
là où il y a des progrès à faire mais je
le dis pas attention je vis dans la vie
qu'est-ce qu'il y a c'est les travaux
pourquoi il y a autant de travaux
oui mais attendez moi ça me fait marrer
parce que tout
[Rires]
le monde
se plaint tout le monde se plaint quand
la chaussée fonctionne pas bien quand il
y a pas de piste cycla parce que les
vélos peuvent faire des accidents avec
les voitures on fait des travaux pour le
mettre en place et ça se plaint parce
que ça avance
oui ça crée des frictions oui ça crée
des gènes ça prend du temps mais quand
c'est mis en place et ben tout le monde
est content et tout le monde a oublié
les gènes et tout le monde
faites pas une patrouille
j'ai le numéro de Ratman voilà on va
prendre
avec plaisir fais des patrouilles dans
la nuit avec plaisir je mets Gilles il
va faire comme ça tu vas voir
ce qui s'est passé il faut le dire c'est
que il y a eu les travaux d'accord mais
il y a aussi le fait qu'il y a plus de
voitures à Paris et il faut que tu
saches très bien le bruit des voitures
la circulation automobile empêcher bien
sûr proliférer
toutes les avenues
je vais te dire on va terminer là-dessus
vous avez foutu une mère de Noah
peut-être beaucoup toi humaine beaucoup
voilà mais je te dis c'est nul une mère
de noire une mère de noire une mère de
noir vraiment
que vous serez content quand il y aura
beaucoup moins de pollution mais arrête
un peu ce qu'on voit en ce moment et des
abeilles
est un peu comment tu continues on met
on va attraper partout et comme ça ça
fait fuir les rats ah ça c'est une belle
ville
c'est la pollution pour les banlieues
arts donc bien sûr vous avez juste
repoussé là-bas
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a réduit la
vitesse c'est aussi pour ça qu'on fait
des transports en commun je vais te dire
la vérité
je vous adore vous avez tout loupé vous
avez tout loupé vous avez [ __ ] Paris
j'avais cru comprendre
pollution vous avez mis des rares
partout la ville c'est catastrophe tous
les gens qui prennent le vélo arrêtent
un peu plus loin vous mettez des espèces
de ploe jaune en place dans Paris c'est
moche par contre
c'était bien passé cette salle non mais
attendez les gens nous ont élu
on nous a élus parce que il y avait trop
de voitures et trop de pollution à Paris
on fait job et maintenant
est-ce que est-ce que vous allez faire
quelque chose pour les rats tu vois la
[ __ ] oui il faut qu'on fasse mieux
c'est quand c'est comme ça d'accord j'ai
pris le numéro de ratmann
Hidalgo ils ont coupé le boulevard où
j'habite en quatre Hidalgo elle s'est
pris pour Osman voilà la défense
attendez on peut on peut moi je pense
qu'il faut faire un peu de Haussmann
notamment je vais vous dire non on peut
sérieux 2 secondes parce que avec
sérieusement
vous avez vu les canicules constat là et
ça va aller que à sanctions si on met
pas si on met pas du budget et de la
volonté politique pour adapter la ville
au réchauffement climatique c'est-à-dire
désolé de le dire mais des travaux pour
pouvoir débit de fumer pour pouvoir
faire de la nature pour planter des
arbres pour pouvoir faire des parcs si
on le fait on va tous fuir Paris parce
qu'on va préparer on a déjà parlé donc
je crois que tu vas voir qui à Paris
donc on peut ok les rats c'est un
problème à Paris l'Académie nationale de
médecine tire la sonnette d'alarme ah ah
oui dans le top 5 des villes les plus
infestées par les rats dans le monde il
faut bosser le truc ça c'est une
évidence
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé sur les rats on fait on
met en place une politique des déchets
ça met un peu de temps à produire ses
effets je veux bien attendre mais on
jugera on jugera